michel fourgous est-ce que vous roulez
en twizy non vous connaissez j'en ai
essayé y essayer une pâle mais s'est dit
sûr par contre sur le coach aurait
comparé de la twizy alors à l'elysée
rappelant qu'il a tant fait l'essayer
c'est ou non mais je l'utilisais la voix
l'a laissé continuer à pouvoir
l'utiliser parce que l'on servait à rien
merci pour ce lancement
sinon voilà vous allez pouvoir
l'utiliser parce qu'il ya un système
d'auto partage qui commence à partir du
18 septembre donc
renault lance sa twizy en autopartage on
écoute quelques explications
quand on s'entraîne on ne paye que les
frais d'adhésion pour avoir son match
pour devenir adhérent voilà et ensuite
on paye à la minutes d'utilisation en
roulage en arrêt temporaire en
réservation
combien de voitures vont être mises à
disposition alors pour l'instant sur la
ailleurs pour l'ouverture il n'y aura
que 50 renault twizy
après on verra en fonction de
l'affluence aussi peut-être alors
quelques précisions d'inscription coûte
15 euros puis la minute est facturé 20
centimes quand on roule 10 centimes
quand on est en stationnement alors un
exemple concret d'autres de trajet vous
êtes à l'université versailles saint
quentin juste à côté d'ici et vous
voulez aller au cinéma à skywest le dur
la durée du trajet de quatre minutes
vous allez compter un peu plus pour
gagner les appeler aux on pourrait à
l'avenir c'est le plaisir de rouler hors
bézy le recul électrique
enfin pour finir cette chronique échos
quelques chiffres dans l'agglomération
les chiffres qui viennent de paraître
on va regarder tout de suite ces
chiffres près de 145 1000 habitants dans
la communauté d'agglomération 79000
actifs environ 7 7500 entreprises dont
plus de 5500 sièges sociaux comme par
exemple bouygues piette ou encore grand
optical pour un total de presque cent
dix mille emplois alors dans le palmarès
des entreprises qui comptent le plus de
salariés sur l'agglomération bien sur
renault avec le technocentre implantée à
guyancourt et près de 10 mille employés
puis viennent bouygues construction et
crédit agricole à égalité à 3500
salariés enfin cassidian du groupe eads
et thales à elancourt avec 2700
collaborateurs une petite réaction jean
marc heber biotic vous travaillez donc à
la maison entreprise de saint quentin
qui est le deuxième pôle économique de
l'ouest parisien
ça fait beaucoup de travail tout ça oui
mais quand on aime on ne compte pas donc
ça c'est la première chose c'est vrai
que le ces chiffres traduisent un vrai
dynamisme de la communauté
d'agglomération de l'ensemble des
services de la caisse qui qui permettent
de traduire voilà une réalité économique
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que au niveau de
la maison de l'entreprise c'est plus de
3000 euros
vous annuel c'est des initiatives que
l'on accompagne des financements sur les
entreprises
différents types de missions fédérer
aussi les réseaux 1 sur ce bassin
d'emploi de saint quentin en yvelines
oui beaucoup de choses passionnantes et
nouvelles tous les jours on parlait donc
des chiffres de l'agglomération malgré
ce qui est affiché à l'écran vous l'avez
compris on parle plus de la twizy
dernier mot sera pour vous dans michel
fourgous et en cours se porte bien
justement sur plan économique au milieu
de saint quentin en yvelines
en tant que maire on a pas de troubles l
archerie long cours mais en tout cas moi
je continue à me battre sur le
financement de l'entreprise puisqu'il ya
deux normes qui vont faire mal
vous savez c'est bâle iii solvency ii
c'est des normes comptables qui du coup
freine le les entrevues les banques à
prêter de l'argent à nos pme et ça c'est
grave et donc et surtout ce n'était pas
le moment
en plus d'aller sur texte et nous et nos
actionnaires c'est surtout pas le moment
de faire partir les riches vous rappelle
que les riches payent 90% des français
payent 80 % l'impôt sur le revenu faut
pas toucher à ces gens là on a besoin de
tout le monde il faut attirer plus tôt
les capitaux les riches en france et les
talents en france parce que nos
entreprises ont besoin d'argent pour se
développer pour créer de l'emploi
donc c'est ça que les français et j'ai
un petit message pour monsieur hollande
qui nous enlève cette taxe de 75% qui
fait des dégâts
c'est des milliers on est sûr c'est plus
de 1000 en essayant chez vous et partie
car jean-michel fourgous tout le monde
dans son rôle d'opposant dans
l'opposition vous avez l'air très à
l'aise on vous recevra donc
régulièrement sur ce plateau vous aurez
forcément des analyses à nous livrer sur
l'économie merci également pour la
maison d'entreprise est venu sur le
plateau mercialys juste très rapidement
puisqu'on va devoir rendre l'antenne sur
cette dernière édition du 7 8 de la
semaine sur le prochain fait l'écho oui
le prochain file echo consacré aux
centres commerciaux puisqu'ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux sur notre
territoire et face à la concurrence ils
doivent se démarquer et puis on
reviendra aussi sur les chiffres du
chômage qui ont grimpé fin juillet
reportages émissions à retrouver sur
notre site internet qui vous le savez
depuis le début de cette saison a fait
peau neuve
n'hésitez pas à laisser vos commentaires
à nous rejoindre également sur les
réseaux sociaux réalisation du 7-8 ce
soir romain respini l'édition du
week-end dès demain vendredi 18 heures
ce sera avec avis gastines justement à
la présentation excellent week end je
vous retrouverai lundi non lundi ce sera
4 il a toujours trouvé un peu plus tard
mais entre 3
il